you know i visualized this moment for so
long you know
nine ten months it would be this
you know next phase of my career you
know what i'm saying so
i felt like i was just chomping at the
bit especially once kobe hit i was just
so frustrated because
i didn't see it end i mean i didn't see
it i didn't see where the future
uh what the season was gonna start in
the future so i was just so
i was going through it so to go through
this felt felt solid and i just got to
keep building one
with you i don't want to take away from
you know what makes
me and kay special because i really want
to implement
you know this group is what makes us
even more special and
they follow i don't even say follow
they're alongside of us
for this journey to aid us in our goals
and
yeah me and kay we have a great
relationship as you can see on sitting
with kai that i did on my platform you
know we have a great relationship
but our synergy carries over to everyone
else
and we allow each other to
teach to learn just do it every single
day
and and when i first you know became
close with kev it was
just built on that you know first it was
just talking about our
you know our circumstances that we grew
up our journeys
and then it transferred into our
activities that we wanted to be a part
of outside whether it be business
whether it be playing together
and we were like man you know this thing
can happen and we had to wait you know
maybe a year and a half
and then it came to fruition and now you
guys get to see a product
that uh has been been worked on for the
last
few months so we we do things to just
continue to
be closer as as brothers but as well as
keep everyone else
engaged with us because our greatness is
even better together than just alone
which is why we're together
there was a lot of talk about the quick
turnaround
for especially the bubble teams but for
a lot of teams from
one season to the next and as as as much
as uh
you know much as they're getting paid
you do feel sorry for them you know they
didn't quite get their time off but that
said they're providing a public service
right now i'm i'm
fully appreciative i mean it is so good
that the nba is back we got our first
preseason action over the weekend
it's just really good to have the nba
back it hasn't been that long you know
what i mean it's not like
you know it's not like good to see you
where you've been but it is really nice
to have it back
so quickly and to have some semblance of
a normal
uh you know late fall and winter having
said that and i don't know if you want
to get into
michael you know the uh the potential of
the brooklyn nets
but i just do want to stick with that
art theme and i do want to
talk i want to combine kyrie irving with
what we saw
from kevin durant's long-awaited nba
return
and brooklyn nets debut um
you know the band you know my one of my
favorite old school r b
bands uh jeffrey osborne ltd you know
you know what i didn't know them right
you ever you ever hear that uh yeah that
song concentrate on you
concentrate on you concentrate on you
you know that song i don't know song but
i
i concentrate on you oh i enjoyed it so
there's a
okay great there's a there's a line in
this song concentrate on you
what jeffrey osborne says it takes
separation to bring appreciation
and that's what i think about when i
watch the brilliance of both kyrie
irving
and kevin durant you know i even
explained but here's the thing let me
just let me just interrupt
you know i cannot hear
you mention jeffrey osborne without
thinking
about bobby j breaking it down
right at your wedding singing love
ballad i know i was raised on jeffrey
osborne what
what we have is much more than they can
see oh man exactly what he's saying
that's what that's what kyrie said what
we have to do
pretty much but concentrate on you is my
joint too
you should listen to that you like it
but no i'm talking i watched
kyrie irving play for the first time
since february
i watched uh kevin durant
play for the first time since june of
2019
uh and i i just i took a moment i was
like this is
this is to be marveled at this is to be
appreciated this is to be admired
this is to be cherished because for all
of kyrie irving's
want to be smartest person in the room
syndrome off the court
he is nothing short of a savant with
that basketball in his hand
and kevin durant as you know michael i'm
not breaking any news
but he's one of the greatest players and
maybe the best pure scorer we've ever
seen
and it's just so good to have him back
kd's career has become
a running conversation about loyalty
and jumping and joining super teams and
you know leaving the thunder to join the
warriors and
and paper legitimate championships
versus illegitimate championships
you know burner accounts it's become
about everything
for a lot of people but his basketball
which is a beautiful sight to behold and
if that's just the beginning of his
comeback
sign me up for uh for league pass alert
because they're definitely going to be a
team that i'm going to be watching not
just
to see if they can contend for the
eastern conference crown but just to
appreciate these two
maestros while we can that's why i'm so
that's why i'm so excited about it my
just from a basketball perspective
what's gonna happen it's the unknown now
the known is
what you just said you've got uh kyrie
irving who
is uh a top 20 player in the nba top 20
top 25 player in the nba
i'd say 20. and you've got kevin durant
who's number two
on my list the healthy kevin durant's
the second best player in the nba
right up behind lebron james you look
good one game in brother let me tell you
look he looked he looked back so
he's healthy if he's healthy okay the
questions
disappear and was that is that benny who
said at one point that he had passed
lebron
according to vinnie you thought that
possible when he when he was shooting
dagger threes in the finals over lebron
yeah even on the warriors it looked like
it was his league at that point
okay so so talent wise i know what it is
and it's fascinating
but talent wise is not talent enough
alone is not going to get you a
championship
and it's going to have to be not just
kyrie irving and kevin durant learning
how to play together for let's say 65
games a year let's just factor in low
management 65 70 games a year
they know how to play together but they
also
know how to bring in the rest of the
team and
they're willing to be coached and
sometimes that means
being told things you don't want to hear
that's what the best coach is
for what it's worth for what is worth
kyrie clarified that today
he did i heard that too he said hey
steve steve's great we got a two-time
mvp coaching us
and steve nash was throwing his flowers
back at kyrie hey you guys don't like
him he's not in your good book but he's
in my good book got it
yeah but on top of that here's the other
thing
criticism criticism it sounds
good what they're do what they're doing
right now 11 days before christmas
sounds good hey
we just this is a we we go we've got a
great relationship we're going to bring
in everybody else
if you deal with any adversity or even
if you don't deal with adversity
and you're in that market you're in
brooklyn brooklyn new york
come on you've got to be able to deal
with the spotlight the spotlight is
going to be constant
the spotlight is going to be harsh and
both of them
throughout their careers have kind of
bristled at that
will they be able to overcome that
i don't know that's because they all
that's what i wanted because talent
cannot
talent can't remove that it's inevitable
like no matter like no matter how
great you are on paper whether you're
the the heat
from the early part of the decade of
last decade uh
whether you are the warriors something's
going to happen
it look it may be this season maybe next
season
something's going to happen that's going
to test you no matter right
you know you're going to even if you
know
listen i wouldn't i don't i don't know
how fans necessarily view
kyrie irving and and kevin durant at
this point because kevin durant has a
lot of
appreciators and he got a lot of haters
still too same with kyrie irving
you know because a lot of people who are
rewarding
are durant's haters do you think
durant's haters are because he decided
to go to golden state is that the is
that the
yes number one thing or is it the bernie
account i think so it's just going to go
and stay former
yeah still still like but for some
people they would never let that go but
the reason i bring that up is just to
say
you know even if now let's say there's a
lot of people like me who are just
excited to watch these two play together
eventually you're gonna become a team
that everybody loves to hate
happen with the warriors remember the
warriors were cute and they were fun
and everybody liked how they passed and
the three-pointers and the splash
brothers
and they became the bad guys you know
and they became the warriors become the
bad guys
what did that happen uh i don't know
exactly when but i mean i love watching
that's unanimous
that's unanimous i love steps you know
well some people just love to hate them
but people were rooting against them at
a certain point steph's unanimous mvp
became a a a a major topic as people
just thought that i was just lebron
too far that's lebron man yeah there's
that too
so no i mean inevitably you're right
they're gonna have to deal with uh with
some noise and we'll see whether kyrie
addresses it with the meteor on rg live
either way you know i'm good i'm good
whatever he decides to do hey thanks for
watching brother from another on
youtube make sure you hit subscribe
before you leave and be sure to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you